one of the things we've been reflecting
over the past few days is just how I
take the polls are as regards the EU
referendum every vote will count in this
and joining me now in the studio is
Simon woolly Simon's from an
organization called operation black vote
and he's been very very clever in what
he's done because you will see behind
him here he is recreated and if you
recognize this you probably recognize
that this is the famous Oxbridge picture
of what was the Bullington club and
there would have been a young David
Cameron in there young George Osborne
young Boris Johnson but instead Simon
what have you done how would you
describe what you've done and why have
you done okay well we've I guess we've
blackened the text right we've turned it
on its head and unchallenged privilege
and power to say actually our society of
British society is multicultural diverse
and dynamic and so we've used that image
really to say to not just the black and
minority ethnic communities but to wider
society this EU debate is fantastically
important I mean want everyone to be
involved this is not for the few but for
the many mm-hmm amount white privilege
and power though I mean they're quite
split themselves and you got all spring
and Cameron who want to remain and get
people like Boris who want to leave yeah
are you in any way urging the people who
you're trying to enlist or enroll to
vote in a certain way I know you want
them to vote that you want them to vote
in a certain way no no that's not our
gift we're saying go to the polls ask
the questions get as much information as
you possibly can but you know this is
too crucial to be left to release to to
the privileged Klaus this is for every
British citizen and the clearly we're
targeting black and minority ethnic
communities and because too often
they're not going to the polls and we're
saying this affects us all equality
immigration prosperity we want these
debates to be discussed and for our
communities to go to the pole why aren't
we seeing that black vote at the poll
stations yes well I mean you know one of
the reasons for that is that when we
discuss issues such as immigration
there's a lot of toxicity there's a lot
of blame pointing at actually black my
ethnic communities so we feel alienated
and accused and we're saying this is our
country we play a positive role and we
need to have our say you know the thing
that always amazed me genuinely me is
his name people think when they talk to
immigrants and people are children of
immigrants that they're going to be very
pro-immigration not necessarily so now
no there's some pushback I mean clearly
there's great diversity within our
community someone to remain some want to
leave what we want to do is to ensure
they're not alienated from the debate
that they feel a genuine stake and I
think without media partners such and
such who have come up with this
brilliant add that everybody sees it
engages in it were they going to see it
Simon we're gonna sit around the country
if they're not engaged say in politics
anyway why would they be watching sky
news well I look to be watching this one
is because of you and your brilliant
presentation but I hope they see their
billboards around the country and in the
newspapers and on our websites you know
it's a great ad it it inspires the
discussion is I hope it translates to
people going to the pole in record
numbers yes but say somebody said look I
have a right to abstain I don't want to
take darkness I don't want any part of
this and what's the bigger message from
you why do you you know give me this
argument yeah why it is you're almost
your duty today's I mean this is a once
in a generation a referendum the
implications are absolutely massive
about who we are as a people that where
do we want to go along along this
political track and you can't complain
about it if you have music important we
have to get involved we have to debate
it we have to unpick it we have to get
the the issues that we want understood
and go to the pole go to the pole in
record numbers and make sure your voice
is heard I hope that happens I mean
we're seeing apathy particularly in
different age groups as well and we know
that we're expecting older people to
turn out is that the same within the
black community you're absolutely right
but that's why we've joined forces with
organizations such as bite the ballot
they focus on young people coming to the
polls operation disability vote so we
want all set
of society to be involved we want
equality actually the issues around
equality to be center stage right so you
want man you want women's races
investigators can I stab it thanks to
having another debate there's been a bit
within the debate feel good man Simon
Willie operation black vote he wants
your vote no matter what way you're
going to vote he just wants you to do it
thank you very much d thank you